SPEAKER: With over 300
sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't
see Create Customer
Value with Google Cloud
AI, then stay tuned,
because here's the Rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of the most
common challenges
with machine
learning is taking it
from a large, daunting
process to something that
actually helps your business.
If you've ever wrestled
with this problem
yourself, then good news.
Here's some advice we
give our cloud customers
as they're getting started.
Maybe you'll find
it useful, too.
Firstly, start simple.
You don't need to build a
self-driving car all at once.
Instead, start with
the simplest problems
you can tackle with
machine learning.
In fact, what looks like a
complex application actually
usually starts out as
collections of separate simpler
components.
Secondly, figure out
the business problem
before you attempt to
figure out machine learning.
You need to have a grasp
of the business impact
your application will have.
Otherwise, you might
just get caught up
in the coolness of a
solution to a problem that
doesn't need any solving.
Thirdly, seamlessly integrate
it into applications
as much as possible, because
ultimately, the end user
doesn't care if it works
with machine learning or AI
or whatever.
They look at the functionality.
Fourthly, machine
learning can open you up
to new user interaction
paradigms that weren't
available to you before.
So don't miss new
opportunities by over-focusing
on old problems.
And finally, even if
it feels daunting,
you should be thinking
big, because AI
is a revolutionary
technology that
will transform all business,
much like the internet
transformed the world
20, 25 years ago.
But remember, you can think
big in bite-sized chunks.
When we work with
customers, we encourage
you to have that big vision.
But we make sure that we work
with you to break it down
into manageable pieces.
And this isn't untested advice.
There's a huge list of
customers that we've
helped achieve success
in machine learning,
and the talk is densely packed
with many of their stories.
If it's customer use
cases and practical advice
you're looking for, do
check out the full talk.
And that's not all
you'll see there.
You'll hear lessons we learned
in becoming an AI company,
and you'll find advice
about the technologies
that we've built to make
your machine learning
journey easier, including some
that are hot off the presses.
We also take a look at how we're
helping solve the skills gap
problem in data science.
The world has 21
million developers,
and of them, only
a few thousand are
skilled at building
deep learning models.
What's to be done about it?
Find out in the full talk.
And if you like
announcements, this talk
brings you three big ones.
First, Contact
Center AI; second,
a new partnership with
Iron Mountain that
lets you use our natural
language understanding
technologies within
their platform;
and the favorite if you
have a need for speed,
powerful new TPU
hardware in alpha.
And for the cherry
on top, you'll
see an AutoML demo
where a Frenchman
teaches you and AI to
recognize soft, round cheeses.
And don't be fooled, turns
out they're not all brie.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]